avoir 20 ans en 2021 c'est la continuité
les 2020 ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que notre jeunesse ça fait onze mois
qu'elle fait des efforts ça fait onze
mois qu'on lui demande de restreindre
ces liens dans des moments où entre 18
19 20 ans eh bien tu as envie de faire
la fête
tu te fais de nouveaux copains tu fais
ta première année de fac tu vas pour ton
premier stage ton alternance tu voyages
parce que tu en mobilité
c'est lé moment où tu goûtes avec
panache aux joies des amitiés des amours
mais surtout de la découverte et bien
d'autres jeunesse on lui a demandé
beaucoup elle a été à la hauteur
elle a été extrêmement résiliente elle a
fait ses efforts elle s'est confinée à
la respecter les gestes barrière elle a
étudié en distance yale pourquoi elle a
fait ça parce que nous avons la chance
d'avoir une jeunesse engagée
nous avons la chance d'avoir une
jeunesse créative parce que notre
jeunesse
elle trouve des solutions elle s'engage
elle s'engage sur nos territoires
mais elle s'engage aussi dans nos
associations elle accompagne les
associations qui luttent contre les
crottes précarité elle fait des maraudes
elle accompagne les liens sociaux dans
nos ehpad ou sur nos territoires près
des grands pas rose de ceux qui en ont
besoin
elle s'engage sur les campus portera
peau du mentorat notre jeunesse est une
jeunesse qui ne baisse pas les bras
notre jeunesse est une jeunesse qui est
de l'énergie qui un panache et une envie
d'avenir
notre jeunesse nous devons la soutenir
et nous devons faire bloc pour la
soutenir
pour accompagner notre jeunesse dans
cette transition plusieurs réponses
puisqu'il n'ya pas une jeunesse en
france il ya des jeunesses de france la
première des réponses elle est
évidemment économique avec le plan un
jeune une solution ses pour que chaque
jeune trouve sa solution qu'elle soit
sur l'accès à l'emploi avec des primes
pour accompagner l'embauchent des plus
jeunes des moins de 26 ans que ce soit
avec le fait de porter de stimuler de
mettre en lumière l'excellence de
l'apprentissage et de l'alternance
que ce soit bien sûr en accompagnant les
plus précaires avec les travaux sur la
garantie jeunes universelle qu'on a
doublé et qui a vocation à être encore
plus inclusive mais c'est aussi cette
jeunesse qui prend le chemin des
formations d'avenir qui se saisit
des opportunités des métiers qui
n'existent pas encore aujourd'hui le
plan un jeune une solution c'est une
solution pour chaque jeune sur chaque
territoire au delà de la réponse
économique
c'est évidemment les chemins
d'engagement nous lui proposons nous la
soutenons avec plus de 100000 missions
de service civique supplémentaire parce
que dans un engagement
évidemment tu donnes tu reçois tu
d'hommes et tu apprends et c'est la
promesse de notre pays ce que nous
devons à notre jeunesse c'est évidemment
de garder un pays à flot c'est de
soutenir et déployer le plan de relance
à plus de 100 milliards c'est
d'accompagner nos entreprises et nos
associations pour qu'elles passent ce
cap pourquoi parce que c'est leur pays
c'est la société dans laquelle ils vont
vivre demain nous devons à notre
jeunesse cet élan nous leur devons ce
soutien et ce soutien en faisant bloc
comment le fait est bien les entreprises
en s'engageant en leur faisant confiance
en offrant des stages malgré cette
situation
decaux vide et de brouillard je dis aux
entreprises faites leur confiance
ouvrez vos entreprises accueillaient les
permettait d alternance ou des contrats
d'apprentissage
je dis évidemment nos associations
appuyez-vous sur la l'énergie et le
dynamisme de notre jeunesse
ils ont soif d'engagement ils ont soif
de sens et nous savons à quel point
aujourd'hui le bénévolat vit également
ce moment de tension parce que plus que
jamais nous devons nous réinventer je
dis évidemment aux parents eh bien
faisons bloc faisons bloc dans nos
familles alors plus que jamais regardons
notre pays comme une nation soyons
solidaires faisons vivre la fraternité
partout et à chaque fois qu'on pourra